CHRIS ARVIN: Hi.
I'm Chris Arvin, a designer at
Mobiata, and I work on the
Expedia app.
The Expedia app lets users book
travel and helps them
along with their travel.
Since the Android design guide
was published, we've
completely redesigned the
Expedia app and held great
Android design as a priority
going forward.
And to do that, we knew we had
to go beyond the design guide
and do a few things
really well.
These included making delightful
interactions for
the user, using "Pure Android"
visuals that also fit our apps
brand, and making sure that
things that are important to
the user are available
quickly.
So when a user opens our app,
they're presented with a
scrolling list of hotels and
flight destinations.
We use full bleed imagery and
magazine-style layout that you
see in apps like the People
app, for example.
And a lot of our users come to
our app to book hotels on the
same night in their current
location, so we make those
available immediately.
And on that same note, if a user
has booked travel with us
before, and their travel is in
progress, we automatically
take them to their trips, where
we show them everything
upcoming that they've booked in
this card-based Google Now
style timeline.
Instead of being hidden under
a drawer or a menu, the
details the user will need for
their travel is available
immediately.
And we love adding little
touches to our app that give
it personality and emotion.
For example, when a user's
waiting for their flight
results to load, we give them
this plane window that they
can play around with by tilting
the phone or moving
the window shade.
And when the flight results are
ready, we show them on top
of this large, beautiful photo
of their destination to
lighten up the data-heavy nature
of flight results and
get them excited about
their potential trip.
And when the user's ready to
check out, we give them the
rewarding interaction of sliding
to purchase, and it's
that simple.
We try to make the entire screen
feel like you're still
in Android, whether it be
from the fly visuals or
the icons we use.
And then we like to take it one
more step and give these
niceties, like how a user can
pull down the photo gallery to
start seeing the entire photo.
Or how they can scroll and see
the parallax of the map in the
background.
And I think it's little touches
like that that make
the user appreciate you
on a deeper level.
And what we've further found
is that our users respond
positively to the attention we
pay to design in the smallest
ways and large ways as well.
Over the past year, our app has
grown from 300,000 active
installs to over two million
active installs.
And we've found that making a
carefully designed Android app
really matters.